haiti's interim prime minister has
agreed to step down
ending a leadership battle that's ensued
since the assassination of president
javel moise
rod joseph told the washington post
newspaper that he
and ariel henry had met privately to
resolve the dispute well let's talk to
andy gallacher in miami
so who's running the country at the
moment
well obviously since the assassination
of juvenile moist on july the 7th there
has been this battle between these two
uh prime ministers but it now seems to
have been settled and
ariel henry will now take over uh claude
josef had assumed that role which caused
a lot of confusion in the country that
really needs stability at the moment but
i think the deciding
factor in all this is that a core group
of international countries
backed ariel on re now that may
bring some solace to the people of haiti
who are in a very precarious situation
since the assassination of java
moise but we're still waiting for free
and fair election statement because
remember
moise had stayed in office a year after
he should have because they couldn't get
elections
up and running that's really what needs
to happen the date for that is late in
the fall perhaps september but again all
the elections i've seen there over the
past few years have been very
problematic but at least this is
uh potentially for those in haiti
worried about their own security
a step in the right direction and is
there any more information coming about
but what actually happened on the day of
the killing
yeah we we have had some reports that uh
in the early hours of wednesday morning
on july the seventh
javanese was desperately making phone
calls to various different
police officials asking for help we're
also getting uh some
reporting that anyone that was making
their way towards javel moise's house on
the outskirts of port-au-prince would
have had to go through
a few layers of security to actually
make it to his house so that once again
raises the question of
who was involved who is the mastermind
behind this attack and we still don't
know that answer
but we do know that none of his security
officials were harmed
in that assassination attempt which
really begs the question who knew
about this who knew what was going to
happen and why were they involved at the
moment there are a couple of key figures
but that seems to change on a daily
basis
so that investigation to find out who
was behind
the assassination of javenel moise is
still ongoing it's cast a very wide net
at the moment there are something like
18
former military people from colombia
involved but
who is behind the attack and why they
carried it out
still seems to be unknown andy thanks
very much andy gallacher in miami